now what we want to do is push on this a
little bit because this is not the only
kind of function we know how to
differentiate we know how to do fit a
lot of different things like for example
this one down here now I'm interested
again just a show of hands who wrote
they aren't so like is this just hands
up straight I want to say 1 2 3 4 5 6 ok
less than half the class think he has
that I'm going to wager that more of you
probably actually did this on your
second line could you raise your hand if
you expanded or third line like if
something like that okay all right again
I'm about about huffy alright thank you
now why do we do this why do we bother
to expand that guy before we go on with
the integration sorry good yep it's kind
of like an instinct because you've
you've turned that problem into a
problem but it looks like all the other
easy ones that I know how to deal with
right I can just go turn my term here
okay however you can see that's easy
because the question I gave to you was
relatively simple if I gave you some
ridiculous power like five or six or
seven you're like forget it I don't sit
here and do all this expanding we just
take a very very long time
okay so what I want to do is see if we
can take an equivalent rule of
differentiation right and then come up
with its equivalent for integration okay
what we're doing here and this comes to
that name that for what's Sophie wrote
here what we're trying to undo if I gave
you this the ug is a particular rule to
differentiate oh you wouldn't expand I
hope what more would G is what we call
this a few differentiate this we would
use the chain rule right because you'll
I don't need to expand this I can just
take the three and do the inside to the
outside I'm good to go okay so I want to
reverse that I'll use the reverse chain
rule okay so if I differentiate I'm
gonna give you something like this here
is something that would require the
chain rule help me work out using the
chain rule what would be the derivative
of this everything for a second just to
get everyone to catch up
mmm I don't get the whole lot so sorry
start me off what's the first thing you
wanna put down just the derivative okay
so you're gonna put the N minus one so
that power is going to reduce we will
get that eventually but I'm gonna
suggest maybe that's not the first thing
that we do there's actually something I
should have done earlier max okay I
should probably have brought that power
out at the front first because if I
bring then minus one at the front that's
actually not the correct derivative is
it so I'll take the index out the front
first then I can reduce the power by one
now in chain rule you guys there there's
two parts right there's the inside and
the outside which one have we done so
far this is the outside there's a thing
big fat thing that's been raised to a
power we've dealt with that now we're
gonna deal with the inside what it's the
inside derivative in this case have a
look if or the inside function is ax
plus B so it's derivative is it's just a
right that coefficient that we know if
you differentiate a constant like B just
it goes okay so I can multiply this
whole thing by a I'm done okay if you
wanted you could write the a at the
front because if they're both numbers
for this is chain or off when you
differentiate so now what would be
equivalent look like for integration
alright let me write something to set us
up and then we'll have a good so now I
want to integrate something that looks
like this we're not doing chain rule
here we're trying to undo chain rule so
let me write something in for us okay so
I've just started off
are you doing about this boy this one
that's a plus I don't like the formulary
use for that one down there oh sorry
sorry
I don't know why I'm doing that I'm
already I'm already doing the outside
because I'm hey okay let's have a look
at this and we'll do it again step by
step right so if he's done so as I can
see three things she's done three things
which corresponds to the three things
that we did for the derivative right so
that's a good that's a good sign
we had three things in chain rule so now
I've got three things to undo chain rule
let's have a look at them step by step
so the first thing that sophie changed
was this does that look right does that
undo what differentiation did it does
right because here we brought the index
down by one here we've increased the
index so thumbs up that corresponds to
that okay the next thing that came was
this N now let's look carefully here
okay this is a division which is
opposite to the multiplication we had
earlier right so this is multiplication
this is division it's on the denominator
but be careful be so careful the order
matters doesn't it in fact it's what I
pointed out with Sarang Sarang wrote
this first
and I said no hold on this comes later
right
this ends not quite right we need to
adjust it a little bit it's it's doing
the right thing
but how should we adjust it and plus one
okay now now it's such a minor
difference isn't it because you I've got
three things to do I just kind of do all
of them right the reason how do we end
up how do we know that it's actually n
plus one and not and so if in your honor
yeah yeah okay this index and by the way
what's great about everything you know
that integration is you can check it
with all the stuff you're very good at
with differentiation right think about
starting to differentiate this thing
just like you did before right the index
would come out the front immediately and
then what would it do it would it would
it would cancel with this n plus 1 right
n plus 1 n plus 1 yeah oh good that's
the integrand I was supposed to get does
that make sense
so some mine and my difference but it is
quite subtle and important all right
last thing this a are we happy with that
guy down there the a that's the a you'll
wonder about okay great so this is the
last step right have a look up here this
is the last thing that we did where we
differentiated because we dealt with the
outside and then we said oh don't forget
its chain rule do the inside as well
okay now this is reverse chain rule in
fact I'm going to write that down
reverse chain rule so when we look at
this n plus 1 and this n plus 1 they
come from the outside function right
they come from something to the power of
n we've dealt with the outside now n
plus 1 n plus 1 but then this is reverse
chain rule we've got to deal with the
inside - so what's the inside derivative
here exactly we're dividing by a to
counteract our multiplication by a but
we would've done with derivative
yeah
ah that's a great question why do we
integrate the outside but differentiate
the inside that was the question right
okay I will address that question by
just finishing this answer off and then
checking it okay um my answer isn't
finished what I need go ahead my cost of
integration always appears okay now
that's a very perceptive question why do
we like what the derivative for the
inside when we were thinking about
integration this whole time
okay well again think about what I'm
trying to achieve with integration I'm
trying to land at something this result
what we call it by the way starts with a
P our primitive right we're trying to
end up with a primitive such that if you
take this guy and differentiate it
you'll land here
okay let's test it let's find the
derivative of this somewhat disastrous
monster okay
it's ax plus B to the power of n plus 1
all over n plus 1 and then an a we might
as well throw in the constant equation
for good measure okay we know how to
differentiate these things let's have a
go what's the first thing that we do you
taught me up here first thing in X he's
gonna come at the front do you agree
that you're next come out the front so
I'm going to do that then this guy we're
still here what happens to me and index
now minus 1 so n plus 1 take away 1 just
gives me n thank you okay
all this stuff is still here on the
denominator right so far you've only
dealt with the outside use chain rule
what's the inside derivative it's a
isn't it I should actually say it over
here so then I multiply by a yep
ah yeah good question
okay so Sarang is asking this plus C
this plus C right we've added that on is
that any is it different to this times a
and hopefully the answer was clear in
what I just said it's multiplication not
addition when we've got this plus C here
I'm differentiating it right now in fact
what happens to it it's gone it's gone
okay so I can disregard it it's a plus
zero on the end here but that that a
that a it's a multiplier or a division
that sticks around it's sort of attached
a little more closely
okay now I've I've done the
differentiation but it's a bit of a
terrible dog reference I can simplify
this right
what can I can't cancel and plus one
goes done what else and this is the
answer to Molly's question right why did
I need the derivative of the inside even
though I'm integrating and the answer is
because I've got to undo that from the
normal chain rule reverse chain rule
undo everything that regular chain rule
did so these are gone that is the
integrand I was hoping for is that okay
all right
now I said to you before that I was
leaving this conspicuous blank in the
heading there okay um question are you
looking at my mess and not like you very
much I'll tidy it up for you know just
we were just confirming we're just
confirming that we're getting years
right okay we have so far called the
result of integration we've called that
a primitive right the corner primitive
however we quickly start to realize that
this function here is not just something
that it's like oh this is where I came
from it's it's own thing and so it gets
its own name it's the result of
integration so we call it an integral
but it's not just any kind of integral
this new word I'm gonna put up the front
here which is going to seem to come out
of nowhere this kind of integral that
we're working on right now is called an
indefinite integral which of course begs
the question what is a definite integral
well we will come to that I'm telling
you this right now because you're going
to encounter this language they're going
to say
work out the indefinite integral of this
or that and what they mean is can you
integrate this place it's the same as
asking for the primitive function you
guys know we often have many many names
for the same thing when we care about it
for different reasons so this is the
name so that you recognize oh okay